Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day in January,
February,
March,
April,
May,
June,
six months.
Then the heavyweight division needs him.
Fuck yeah.
Jon Jones,
first heavyweight fight,
Brock Lesnar.
Bah Bah Bah Bah.
You're welcome.
BOMP bomp bomp bomp bomp yeah.
Imagine that fight.
The only problem is if you think so,
yes.
Mark them in the grappling.
I think you're just completely died.
Can fucking steel pig would fucking pissed.
Pissed that go and he'll fuck Brock Lesnar cause they'll say it.
You better do the fuck steroids you pick is crazy.
I mean I love that motherfucker.
Yo Chick.
I love him.
I love them to immigrant mentality.
Bring them on.
Give him more fucking steroids.
What's that?
You want another America
definitely born and raised in Cleveland,
Ohio.
But when it's got that fucking crazy blood in them and he don't give a fuck bro,
he proved the listening.
He proved it.
Went with fucking Overeem.
You don't give a fuck.
Put Him in there with the product at all.
That the waste to the guilt.
Fucking Brocklin who just rag doll pull Mark Paul poured more Mark Hunt fucking
gay.
But mark has never been the kind of grappling and steep is.
Oh No.
I think Steve Bay beach.
You know what?
If he punched a steep in the face,
it's going to get more steam out of his fucking he is.
And you saw
last night coming back back last name that because he's not going to come back
and fight for a world title right away.
You don't think so?
I think it's the biggest embarrassed,
clear the fog.
That would be a crazy for the biggest fucking embarrassment of the year.
Why would that be embarrassment?
It's embarrassing.
It's just embarrassing it because it's Mark Hunt.
They knew he was on the juice.
He went in there loaded to the gills.
It was just an imbalance.
It was an embarrassing thing for everybody.
And Mark Hunt that every fucking right to be mad.
They put them in there with a guy that's coming off rocket fucking fuel.
That dude,
don't just throw the deep ball.
What is the size of his fucking head?
He's taking shit that makes you a fucking head grow
a fucking pit.
Bulls.
I hope they put them against my yoke.
Chick.
I will fly to fucking clean back gum.
It's climate con climbing a mountain.
I found the snot in my nose.
It was bigger than this gum.
The Ed.
They had to take the gum out to eat it anyway.
Oh was so long.
It was like a cookbook book.
I got a flashback from the hell that motherfucker.
Anyway.
Oh booger.
Cause I love him.
I love him.
From time to time I have a little pimple squeeze it and it just comes out and
it's got like a little clam board with you with all this Steve Shit.
From time to time.
Oh,
when you eat,
when you can quote for 30 years.
It's a habit.
You wake up in the morning,
pick one out.
It's like a candy cane with coke.
You inhale that motherfucker.
It's like going to the dentist for free.
I will throw up on this fucking table.
Do you ever do
that?
To be honest with ourselves,
we're all friends here.
That was the most fucking thing I ever seen.
I agree.
They knew he was on it and they put that fucking animal in there.
Okay.
And you know what,
man?
Go ahead.
Keep doing those steroids.
Put them in there again,
spiel,
but whatever.
I love that Cleveland motherfucker.
Dude,
kill him.
He'll fucking kill him.
And General Stevia,
they would ever be able to have him come off a suspension and fight for the
title.
That's not how it goes.
Ah,
they've done billion dollars though.
Even a scab off and Iranians head right now.
Right now,
they're fucking sitting there going,
we lost Ron.
Take the gum out of your mouth.
Dry Pavement.
They lost Rhonda.
And the only other thing,
we got his fucking cotton and he's having a baby.
He don't want to fucking come back.
Now.
You know what he's talking about.
He might come back there,
but they don't want to give him who he supposed to fight.
Who is he supposed to be supposed to fight that fucking collar?
Beep and end of story.
No more fucking around that one.
Then let's do it.
Let's set it up.
No,
that's not
my job
to find out though.
You don't need to fight nobody.
He's number one,
right?
Or is it was your boy number one Tony Khabib's number one.
Then that's the fight enough and he was number one and then Khabib Kim became
number one.
Why did could be a leapfrog Tony?
I don't know.
Who knows the ranking cause he talked goes to only fought a couple of times and
I don't know if he's the one is he is my number one brother could leaves number
one.
Well that's the thing you did.
Listen,
he's fighting now.
He's available today.
He's available for Brooklyn.
He said it when he fought against Michael Johnson.
He's available for fucking Brooklyn.
Okay.
He's available for Brooklyn entry.
Let's get Eddie against Raphael.
That's a good fight.
Let's get that sent back in that people like watching him live.
Very.
Let's get,
let's get,
we got some fucking people here.
Okay.
A lot of good guy.
He sells paper views now it's around 300,000 but he's,
he's always Robbie Lawler that got as good fucking they got.
Joey needs to be the matchmaker.
Fucking got it.
Okay.
Well No.
Yeah man.
It's an interesting situation.
Got Plenty of good fucking fight.
I want to give us the fights.
Whitewater seat.
No problem.
That's the beep and the story.
There's no outdoor,
no Tony Ferguson.
There's no babies.
There's no nothing,
but he has a poor boy.
He's got a baby.
It's not a big draw for me to fuck 20 million on you.
The baby's weight six weeks,
but kindness already got 20 million.
That's the difference.
He wants to take time,
not breadth of his,
his,
his life is more important than what the UFC was,
was running the show.
I agree with you,
but right now then May 5th may labor on Memorial Day weekend.
It's called [inaudible].
I beat,
I beat Ferguson,
Ferguson,
Sharon.
Let's have some fun.
You're Ferguson so wrong.
Let's have some fucking button.
It's a fire siren is not fighting 55 again.
I didn't say that,
but we're all mixing.
We're all mixing weights right now.
Did we not say that before?
They want to put out,
go against.
Could be,
but no.
All those thinking about moving up.
Any moving up anyway,
so who gives a fuck?
It seems like he's Kinda of it like a chess move.
Like Jason said,
Connor fee.
Once that fight,
that's what everybody wants to see you again,
whatever the fucking orders,
but the order that they're trying to put together is the order that I don't want
to see because they have to sell paper,
but they're going to do this.
Okay.
This is the route you flux.
He's telling us they're going to,
they're going to bring him back against fucking the black dude at one 70 that's
the fight.
Tyron Woodley.
That's already been made at the thing that when it comes to get slow the fuck
down.
Watch it,
watch it,
but we just said that Woodley's going to fight Bisbing and catch I.
I know,
I know.
That's what great.
They're gonna fight one.
You think that Tyron Woodley is going to fight her own willy that was already
established in New York.
Tyrone Woodley,
Tyron,
Tyron Woodley is already going to fucking fight.
I'm okay.
That's the first fight.
Then they're going to try that.
That's the fight.
They're going to put that one 70 maybe in May.
What happens?
It could be then,
then.
Then this is what this is.
This is my decision.
This is beyond you.
This is beyond I this and I haven't really seen the setup at the fucking New
York for you fucking blind because you didn't see what I see and talk to them.
I know you talked to them,
but then I'll tell you the deck that I'm talking to them so you didn't know who
I did.
I loved the ad.
Understand,
but the problem is here that that was,
the seed was already planted in New York.
It was already planted.
None of you motherfuckers saw it.
What do you guys watch?
What seed?
The seed of him talking back and forth with Tyrone.
Tyron Woodley.
Okay.
That's the fucking feet.
Jesus Christ.
The fucking seat.
Smells like a zoo.
He's going to look up.
He's going to look at these.
You already at the press conference.
He could be.
He said,
oh,
he doesn't fight enough and get,
wait,
what's going on here?
That's Wayne's talking shit.
That's the seed.
You're dumb fucks.
That's what's happening here.
What is he saying?
He's just talking shit.
You hear what he said?
I don't think so.
It went on and then timeline said,
somebody said,
hey,
come out.
Like you're lucky I don't come to seven days.
We can do it.
Look at him trying to be cute with them for a moment here.
There's a moment saying,
hey bro,
going between Tyron Woodley and it got set up right there.
Okay,
so that's the next fucking fight,
Conor saying we can do it at 70 we can tell you that Joey's Dick,
because you see what you want to fucking see.
That's the next fight.
They already,
he already planted the fucking feet.
He's not going to fight Tyrone.
He's going to fight Tyron and killed one time for canopy.
Like they threw Dennis deeper with Frankie.
Edgar was fucking working
through Dennis.
That is safe as available.
You know the color of his skin so already gets,
he's talking some truth.
It's in between fucking he's,
he doesn't want to fight Ferguson.
He's dropping a fight.
Tony Ferguson.
Why not just bro,
it's too much height and Tony Ferguson don't give a fuck.
He's a bugbear backstage again,
fucking Florida.
That is a horrible for me,
it's tremendous.
It's tremendous.
It's like a zoo.
Oh,
look at this.
They're gone.
Fuck with.
Get some volume on that.
Can we get volume on that back there?
Oh,
here this go all the way back.
Way Back.
There we go.
Crank it up.
He's setting it up.
She's setting up the one shot.
There's eight guys,
big guys
with that phone.
Whoa.
It's crazy.
There's 10 guys.
Look out.
Drain Tyron looks.
Let's hit rewind it again.
We went in the Sh sh
nothing much.
You're that lady to,
you said what's up?
And he started crying.
I said,
what's up?
He said,
not much,
but meanwhile you look at Tyron.
Tyron looks so drained there.
When he made that weight is like right after he made the way
he's going to go for three fucking cops goes,
nobody ever saw this shit.
He doesn't know what.
He's not going to fight Ferguson because it's a fucking,
it's arrow.
Smith guns and roses was Aerosmith on steroids and Tony Ferguson is little Diaz
with fucking
blood in them.
You understand me?
He didn't want that.
You know,
I'm Tony Ferguson and Dana.
It's not a draw paint and junk.
Well,
John,
Uncle Bobby Dana is not going to let his nephew fight collar be kidding.
Connor versus Tony is not a draw.
It's not a draw for Conner.
I know.
He's your guy.
That's a big fucking fight.
Make a total big fucking side though.
Why do you think they're making it?
Eddie?
You tell me.
Why do you think they make us?
It's not going to self and I love these guys.
Don't get me,
I'm not,
I'm not clowning your guy.
But as far as the average consumer buying a paper view,
that's not a cell.
It's just not hell.
Yeah,
it is.
I just kind of fighting,
fighting a top challenger is always a sale and Tony,
but Tony Ferguson is most certainly a top challenger.
When Nate Diaz fought Conor for the first time,
it was a giant fight because Nate Diaz had a name and he's a bit,
he's a bigger name than Tony,
arguably for sure.
Not even close,
much bigger now after he beat them for others.
And Tony wasn't the same as it is now.
It's a different,
it's a different thing now,
but,
but he had it because of nick and nick had had all the strike force success,
elite Eggsy success,
you know all that is a lot of TV time.
There's the ultimate fighter winner,
Nate.
And then on top of that,
nick had just got done beaten Anderson or fighting Anderson Rather.
And you know nick,
nick is like a pretty well known figure,
right?
His brother,
they're both the Diaz brothers are like,
so that's a different level.
But having them take that fight on short notice too.
But Connor was the main draws my point
because I agree,
it's,
he's the main draw.
If you're calm and you're his manager,
he'd go and let's fight Tony,
who's a tough fucking matchup,
but he's not as big as the name is.
A guy like Nate Diaz at 55 who we're going to make more money,
maybe not as tough as a fight bigger name.
So they're doing it from the business point and not fighting,
not fighting can be.
You also have the fight in horrible fight for,
they're going to do a Russia card and when they do a Russia card they want to do
a rush card with Connor or with hubby brother.
So when they do a rush,
a car with a beam,
it's most likely going to be for a title I would imagine like so a title.
It all depends.
If common accepts,
that reminder might be Tony and in my parents room and apparently they offered
it to Tony and Tony said that he wanted to make the same amount of money that
Habib Manx.
It's just perfectly fun at first,
but you know they said,
nope,
you got a contract,
you got to honor your contract.
That's at least how it's been explained.
Yes.
That's how it's been explained.
They go,
nope,
well you sign these contracts,
you got to honor the contract.
Yeah,
but that,
that,
that only works one way.
The only works for the UFC because they don't honor all the contracts.
They,
what do you mean for works for they can cut them.
They can.
You have a six week contracts and you've lost two,
but that seems contrary to cut.
It's in the contract that you can get cut if it wasn't in the contract.
There's guys who have fought and they fought out their entire contract for sure.
Right.
But I'm just saying,
hey Joe,
here's the ones,
I remember the early days and Pedro Huizar had this giant contract because they
thought the page was going to be the heavyweight champ.
And so they were giving him like undercard fights.
He's making quarter of $1 million.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's tricky man.
Because I get the,
the idea that they would want to protect Konner um,
you know,
and,
and really set up the big money fights,
especially now because he's the biggest guy.
But then you've got Connor who's kind of fucking crazy and he's like,
well,
the way he is John down tire and literally he gets,
or Dune,
I think it from,
from a business standpoint,
they're going,
wow,
what's the biggest fight pot?
Let's say you have three fights left.
Who are the three biggest names we can fight and to make this happen.
So you stay on to feel big and make the most money.
He might not be under feet.
I mean he's definitely not undefeated now.
Right,
but the biggest thing is the Woodley fight because that's a one seven.one seven
that's a third belt guys.
That's a fight.
As
much control on you motherfuckers up.
You didn't see it.
Number two,
listen,
I'm not saying if the Khabib is going to be,
especially after,
I actually don't talk to take the punch from Michael Kahn.
I'm not saying Michael Michael Johnson,
but the fight is could beat and then the next fight has to be Ferguson.
If he beats him,
not just the way it is,
which I Cook Ferguson,
we can't wait.
They can't wait like fridges and needs a fight like in the next four or five
months.
It could be me as a fight in the next fucking two,
three months.
I said,
don't fight in Brooklyn
from now.
When you went to view them.
Yeah,
he put the hat on your Mustang.
He said,
you'll fight in Brooklyn.
Put her hat on my head every time I put it every time.
Right now.
It's great.
I fucking love where that and you don't say he looks at me and shows me the hat.
I give him the nod like yeah,
I put that hat on.
I like that hat.
Me As a fan,
I don't want to see is Tony Rush.
Gabby.
That's,
that's a fight.
There's not a better match up.
I can be made into movies.
I don't know about that.
I like Tony versus Connor.
I even like a beat versus Connor.
Yeah,
I like,
I like Connor versus Woodley.
I like that to fight to fight.
That's the next money fight.
But he's going to eventually,
I don't think the UFC gives them enough power to do that.
I can get that.
Yeah.
He's got all the power.
Well here's the thing about doing cowardly loses to Bisping.
If he loses those catch weight fight,
he still keeps that 170 pounds strap.
That's if that catch that.
That's just he my,
no,
he can't hold on to divisions.
I run against my board cause I gotta go to,
right.
I'm telling you,
they were going after Tyro planted the seed,
right.
There are two divisions.
It's been backstage at u of C's.
All the guys.
That's exactly what happened when I'm away from the Russian as either as long as
they can,
but specifically we can talk over each other.
No,
they'll do the NASA thing when they go to interview and they die in car
accidents and shit,
but that's the fight guys.
That's the fight right there that everybody wants to see right off the bat.
I love to see Conor and could be by love to see Ferguson and Khabib,
but they don't know to do that right off the bat.
They're going to hope that they fall off a cliff or a plane goes down.
Let's give him the money for it,
which is one 70 can get the third belt.
Here's the thing,
if he does lose,
if he goes up to [inaudible] tire and nothing happened,
habits risk free,
it's free.
It's free.
Same thing with that.
Nate,
Nate Diaz,
phone number.
Who runs this shit?
What'd you do?
What'd you do with Tony and Khabib?
They go to Bella top.
Hell no going to say,
fuck you,
UFC,
we can't take this no more.
Okay.